you have something to give back  [Music]  all lives have equal value but we don't  treat them that way just because of  where you're born in the world has a  determining effect of whether you're  going to survive to your fifth birthday  that is not equal opportunity  [Music]  over 20 years i've learned in  philanthropy there are so many different  ways to give time money expertise your  voice i'm not going to teach you which  organizations to focus on that's very  personal and that's up to you but i will  be offering you a framework and a way to  think about giving go to where your  passion is what is the thing that you  wake up thinking about in the morning  you say ah  why is this happening in my community i  don't believe in this you do  philanthropy because you believe deeply  that you want to leave the world a  better place  [Music]  you